[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
what's up welcome to hey babe sal looks
a little different
today he's taking the form of joe derosa
and i've just been talking to joe derosa
for the last couple of minutes and he
keeps saying i got a nice apartment in
manhattan
and if he says manhattan one more time
i'm gonna throw him off his own balcony
it's manhattan dude it's manhattan bro
pimp is it manhattan or manhattan
why is he pronouncing the man man why do
you think
i don't know actually dude first of all
they're gonna have to change it to they
hatten pretty soon
i mean you came in first of all late i'm
sorry about that
yeah dude comes in hot and he goes let's
go as soon as he gets here
i'm already filling in for sal today
casal is still out
uh on vacation and when is he gonna
realize that he's gotta work a little
bit too i mean it's just i mean the
guy's always on vacay
it's just he just bothers me
dude i wore a wrestling shirt today just
because i knew sal wasn't gonna be here
so i needed one of us to have something
wrestling on
or else the fans would flip out they'd
be like hey how come there's no
wrestling thing that's so funny dude
yeah
but no you you came in you came in real
hot today no i know i'm sorry uh he
calls me up listen to what this
pimp doesn't bleep him for you he does
believe him but we only get two bleeps
we treat this like true tv
all right you only get two bleeps pimp
bleeps us left and right on taste buds
yeah because
dude it's him i could never do a an hour
solo show an hour show with you without
cursing because
you're from delaware county pennsylvania
look i want to talk about
i don't want to get baptized the priest
goes welcome to the
community that's two that's two bleeps
oh yeah uh i wanna i'm gonna talk about
the fact that
he so we're recording in my apartment
today which is wonderful by the way
thank you
and you call me this morning and go he
leaves me a voice memo
this morning he goes this is the kind of
animal you're dealing with i should save
this for an episode of disstefano for
instagram because uh there's but there's
no shortage of things to complain about
you about whatever yeah he calls me
leaves me a voicemail he goes he goes
bro let's get breakfast
and he goes dude seriously water up some
egg sandwiches and some coffees i'll pay
for it
seriously pull the trigger i'll give you
half
[Music]
immediately retracts yeah it's his idea
his offer then retracts from i'll pay
you half
or i'll give you the money to pay you
have because i started doing the math in
my head and i'm like well you know joe
lives in downtown manhattan so anything
around it's probably
expensive and not only is joe a pig
talking about the poor cheddar pop-off
but the homeless pimp is here on edibles
so he's going to want to eat probably
you know 10 sandwiches
so i was like and sal's not here to put
it on the company card i'm gonna i know
it just it sucks when he's not here just
like sal
you're just gonna pay for it and he's
like all right fine i'm like
dude you and your friends did the garden
you're gonna buy me an egg sandwich
oh my god i did the garden it was in
somebody's yard
i would have loved to look back like
just get a camera in
on like sal joe murr and q
when they were like 22 years old like
hanging out at some [ __ ] dive bar
in staten island and be like one day
these guys are gonna sell at madison
square garden
i mean it's insane you know when each of
them moved into the nice neighborhoods
they now live in
it was a there goes the neighborhood
situation yes it was
how did these guys get into this tax
bracket yeah it's one of those things
where like you know
like like the neighborhood like the the
other the rich neighbors and wherever
they live we're probably like
who lives here the what
what is this no but uh it's great we
miss sally's on vacation having fun
i know we do miss xiao we love shout
outs love style baby this might be our
chance remember we were going to do a
thing called the sao show of chris and
joe where we just talked about sal for
an hour
should we do should that be this hey
babe it's just it could be
literally just talking about sal i mean
yeah he um
wait what do you got impractical joker's
the origin story hey what's up everybody
go to chrisdcomedy.com we got stan
updates coming out
we got providence rhode island
philadelphia pennsylvania we've just
added dates
dania improv miami florida just added in
september waukegan illinois
uh mohegan i'm sorry foxwoods in
foxwoods connecticut october 23rd
zany's nashville christy comedy.com
phoenix is coming up
west palm beach we're going to put that
on sale soon and thank you so much
uh yeah but i see here's the thing with
the impractical jokers fan base is a lot
of them
i'm sure listen to hey babe and taste
buds anything we say about the jokers
they know already like they have the
origin story tattooed on their
feet i mean their fans are hardcore dude
i would kill to have fans like that
my fans are very supportive and nice but
not like the joker's fans
well here i gotta be honest with you
though because you haven't hit the road
yet
we just me and pimp just went out to
providence rhode island comedy
connection
shout out thank you for all the fans
that came out it was like a beautiful
thing to see like the amount of people
that came out it was just great
but pimp you can't even attest to this
literally dude when you go back out on
the road
like getting the fans from these
podcasts it's different now they were
giving homeless pimps standing ovations
when they saw it i'm talking about race
i would say this give it up
and they got up and they stood up there
was somebody wearing corduroy pants
because they want to dress like the pimp
so like the fan things have changed so
i'm not saying
you know it's joker's level but dude the
the we
you have some adoring fans you guys want
to see me i haven't been out on the road
in two years you guys want to see me
come back out should i come back out and
do something
every 10th ticket i'll get i'll get a
free sub
you'll get a free provolone and capicola
oh my god dude i might have made a
mistake
i know bro when everything was locked
down it seemed to make sense to open a
sandwich shop now
stuff
i sent the investment portfolio to my
county went oh
did you as well do it though did you
look at it i asked chris to
invest in my sandwich i'm opening an
actual brick-and-mortar spot my partner
yeah on the lower east side and i asked
chris i asked chris
to stefano to invest in it yeah what
state am i in that i'm asking you to
invest
usually investors are men with suits and
money
in class i'm in a hulk hogan t-shirt
at lululemon shorts because you and i
share the same account and he was like
are you sure you want to do this i was
like
pull the trigger he was like all right
it's your money man
he was like you might as well just put
it in between two slices of bread and
throw some mayo on it
because he's going nowhere oh that's so
funny here we go
what percentage of restaurants fail
sixty percent of restaurants fail within
the first year of operation
and eighty percent fail within the first
five here's the difference
i'm not opening a restaurant i'm moving
in a sandwich shop that has a bar
inside change that change that here here
pimp
go percentage of bars fail in new york
city
keep that we're not talking about
collegeville pennsylvania two percent
dude if you fail will you will you open
the shop back up in phoenixville p.a
i mean probably i open it at soul joel's
comedy tent
my god dude sojo's making more money
than all of us yeah i know dude
dude he got he gets every comedian
that's where i think i genuinely think
when we finally decide which is going to
come very soon to finally launch the
patreon which i promise you is happening
soon the patreon is happening soon
we we already have it in the works so
good news coming soon
but that and the the first
hey babe taste buds live shows i
even though i know we could go to a
theater and we could do that because
because because of the fans that we love
so much thank you for all the support
from the fans i know they could put us
in a big venue now but i still think we
got to do it in a tent in pennsylvania
i just think that's what we deserve
that should be the first one man dude i
did soul joel's parking lot in a tent in
january
dude outdoors with space eaters
oh my god dude and then i could go into
while we're doing the show i could go
into a local hoagie shop
and do and do quasi celebrity hoagie
making
yes yes dude dude
we were talking about me and pip were
talking about because my show backyard
bar wars as you calling did backyard
bombers which i want to tell you dude
true tv now is gonna go along with
calling it backyard barn wars
because i've caught not like publicly
but like mess around on twitter
because are you serious because our fans
our fans from the hay bay podcast and
the christy chaos podcast
have literally rolled with backyard barn
wars as i said like joe derosa called it
background bombers and
are you serious well no not yet but they
stay told me they're like
hey you can tweet backyard barn wars
like we're going to start repo
we love the branding of that because
your fans seem to really be engaged they
told me yesterday that is why
that our show other than practical
jokers but in the history of true tv
is the most engaged on social media ever
besides
obviously jokers which but that is why
they said it's all because of this [ __ ]
because the back they make that is
because that's what it is and that's
what it should be yeah
it's an animal servicing other animals
in their yards yes and you can you can
you can try to soup it up all you want
with robotic
arms and tiki torches or whatever the
hell it is you do on that show
but i mean it's it's a pig show i'm one
of those guys where i'm such a pig
it would literally you'd be better off
having me keep my shoes on when i got to
your house because if my hooves touch
your
property it's even worse it gets even
muddier
i'm sorry i looked at my phone by the
way i was texting with sal
that he had because we forgot i got he's
gotta launch the po we're also doing
taste buds today yes and i'll be the
guests on taste buds yeah so it's a it's
a real crossover work week here at the
no pressure network
um actually they'll see that they'll see
the taste buds before they see this okay
you already saw the taste buds
anyway i had to text sal to make sure
that he put the poll out
because we always do it on his twitter
this is our life like you legally have
to be like hey we can't start taste buds
because sal didn't tweet out a poll
about games it's just disgusting it's
just it's a disgrace
it's a disgrace dude and i'm telling you
man here's the truth of the situation
is if we keep going and we keep getting
the support from the fans which again
thank you very much
we could genuinely like our live like we
could literally be
like bona fide superstars off taste buds
and hey babe
like selling more tickets than anybody
i'll tell you something dude
every every week at least once a week i
go into
to the charitable rankings and i just
want to see
who's in the top 100 of podcasts that
week
the pig show in this top 100
it is a disgrace it is it's it's you
it's taste buds it's hey babe yeah it's
that [ __ ] animal santino
it's bobby lee yeah these are the guys
yeah like make like dude it's disgusting
dude andrew santino drives a [ __ ]
tesla santino the chicago trash he is
i mean my god dude oh my god almighty
this
whole thing it's so good sometimes i see
versey in there
oh he's god his special
oh every time every time he does a promo
he's got the camera from under here
you can always tell he just came off you
can always tell he
literally if any time paul versi turns
on his camera which
go go check out paul verzi's podcast
with bill burr um it's fantastic and
paul versus solo party anything better
anything better with burr than the versi
experience uh uh
with with paul but dude and every time i
watch
his stuff i'm like if i pan the camera
just anywhere on his body
there's a sauce stain somewhere you just
know there is
you just know there is like on his pants
on the back of his shirt
oh my god his pa so his solo part is
called the paul versi experience
the versi experience isn't it called tv
i've had that experience
it's called i want to go home dude you
know what's infuriating to me is that
you're in a diet look at him he's got a
water bottle
it's like chris what are you doing i was
i was such a
i mean i know you're the big animal of
the two of us
but i was such a pig this weekend it was
so disgusting
i i didn't have spots okay on fridays i
had nothing on friday or saturday i was
telling pimp before you got here
i went to the clubs each night as if i
was working
and just hung out and drank all my like
the next thing you know it's like 2 a.m
3 a.m i'm leaving i'm coming home
i'm making like leftovers i'm eating
tacos on my couch i got i got
wendy's on uh sunday delivered delivered
yeah that's how you know dude
it was so cold it was so cold by the
time i got here and i just ate it cold
oh you ate cold meat and i called my
buddy brian up and i go dude
i gotta i go i gotta stop i go i go
i'm i'm drinking too much i'm eating too
much
i'm not exercising i can barely even do
a push-up
yeah i'm like i gotta turn things around
dude i gotta start meditating again
whatever and he goes dude you name like
10 things
just start eating a little better
tomorrow and maybe doing a little mild
exercise that's true
and i was like all right you're right
and i ordered some 20-pound dumbbells
because those always have treated me
well in the past
and i got an exercise mat so i can lay
on the ground dude you have no room in
here to do anything
the cameras usually aren't here
it's like it's a prison cell workout you
need tt jerry over here
your instructor yeah dude i could have
sex with guys in here yeah dude
now i'm listening yeah uh and then i
and i just i just was like let me just
cut out some bad foods and like just
start trying to eat okay but
okay all right fine it's still drink but
only drink certain things
tequila or vodka that's what i'm doing
okay but okay but let me ask you this
how long do you think it's actually
gonna last like how committed are you
dude
i've done this honestly i've done this
one before i usually can stick with it
pretty good
this is the one i can stick with no
because i remember one time this was
like three years ago
um we were sitting down we were with um
the great ann harris who used to work at
comedy central
who was the greatest she we were all
having like a comedy central uh
lunch that they were taking me out to
lunch for a deal i had in the works and
then derose and she goes hey do you mind
if joe derosa comes along i was like
for what and then he shows up and he
goes i'm i mean
i'm doing keto now and i was just and i
remember
asking the waiter you were like hey what
do you cook this in or can i have this
with no bread and then he wound up
eating
rolled up i didn't even remember this
probably rolled up ham with feta cheese
and i remember i swear to god there's no
way i ate ham rolled up with feta cheese
there was something that you asked for
something wrong like basically you
ordered a sandwiched out the bread
and they gave you cold cuts or something
rolled up and it was like fettuccine i
remember going to lunch
i remember going to the dodgers game
with you you remember coming with it was
me
ann and chloe remember chloe from comedy
central
no we're at a restaurant downtown and
you just showed up and you
i remember you were on keto at the time
and we were all eating like these great
beautiful meals and then he came in
and you were like explaining your diet
she was just about to get into
i'll never forget she was just about to
get into like what the plans had for me
comedy central and he showed up
and i mean whoever got playing and then
she got fired yeah yeah
what plans yeah exactly yeah you had a
you had a four-minute tv show the
episodes were four minutes chris would
once again sit in a bar because they
knew what they were dealing with
and asks you you would ask five
questions stupid questions
what an original show idea it was real
groundbreaking
uh you did it you did an app i did do it
because they paid me two grand
i thought you did
drink whiskey while you ask me four
questions of course i did it
of course i did it i know dude i love
like all these deals i've had all these
opportunities and
i'm just always back on a couch in one
of my friends houses it doesn't matter
what you what you promised me yo i'll
always wind up back on the couch
somewhere
dude yeah you're you're like you're just
like uh you i'm trying to think of a
you know you're like in like can't buy
me love or one of those movies where
you're like the piece of [ __ ] that gets
allowed into the nice group for a little
while and in the end you realize you're
just a piece of [ __ ] you have to
and you go back to your original place
you have like two such like little
beautiful daughters and i'm like
how oh god i'm cause i'm repulsive
nobody
my kids are so cute
well you should tell derosa how you've
been sneaking pizza in the middle of the
night
you ready for this and we got pictures
of it too yeah well did we post it
already on the
no no i'll put a christy comedy patreon
not yet okay well so we'll put it up
we'll put it on this
on this episode dude so we were in
providence rhode island last weekend
and i've done this twice now i did this
in la and i did this i did this in
providence so last weekend
we go um uh uh here i got the order too
so we we go back to the room we had
great shows we had so much fun
and then and then i'm like you know what
i'm going to turn in like we'll have a
good day we'll work out tomorrow with
sergio chicone it'll be great
so we're in bed i had drank like five or
six vodka sodas i was so drunk homeless
people to drive my car
home he had no choice well five or six
is enough to have to be driven
i agree you shouldn't drive but you were
you were shit-faced from five or six
yeah dude i'm like a lightweight bro
how fast you drink them i drink them
pretty quick i think that's i consumed
them too quickly
but i i was like hammered i could not
drive so no or sergio drove right not
you
my tolerance is insane anymore dude it's
insane
it takes you so long to get drunk right
i could
i get it's a lot it takes a lot it's a
problem dude i mean
it's a problem or it's not a problem it
depends on how you look at it now come
on here we go i know i know i know
you're on a diet right now but how good
does this sound
picture yourself domino's doesn't sound
good no it's not dominoes picture
yourself
2 30 in the morning in the middle of
providence rhode island
in the downtown marriott hotel buzzed
out of your face
just like you're just feeling like
you're so hungry
you you've thrown your inhibitions to
the wind and then you go to cecilia's
pizzeria on
seamless and you order a cheese stuffed
pizza medium with mushrooms
and it says in parentheses this serves
three to four people
and you got it anyway then you get a 20
ounce bottle of diet coke
of course you're gonna top it off you
get a tiramisu that was three dollars
and 33 cents
that's what i ate is that expensive for
a tiramisu or cheap
no do you have a picture of the pizza
yes we have a picture of the pizza that
we sent
dude it was it was one of those pizzas
that's like a cake why'd you just get
mushrooms
i don't know i don't think like
pepperoni or something because i was
dude i was drunk
i was good uh honestly it hit the spot
like at the moment it was good but i
felt like garbage after what did you
think of that well the next day you were
dead oh it looks great
it's like the upside down pizza with the
sauce yeah it was like a cake pizza
so shout out to cecilia's pizza in
providence it looks like it's also got
onions or something
i think they probably through what was
how much of that did you eat
the entire thing shut up chris i swear
to god that's what i'm saying dude chris
in one sitting yeah
do i look what i mean you don't look
thin right but you don't look fat i mean
compared to for with you if you're doing
[ __ ] like this you should be a lot
bigger i should be here you ate that
whole pizza
yeah and how long like i
honestly do 20 minutes tops shut up
20 minutes time to crush two the crust
ii and the tiramisu and they gave me the
tiramisu in like a like a styrofoam box
that they used to give big macs and
mcdonald's in
i don't understand how you you could eat
that in 20 minutes dude because i was
drunk and then i had a diet coke so i
didn't feel so bad
dude you i do that dude i got a diet
coke with my wendy's dude and then i was
supposed to i was supposed to
work out with sergio ciccone who's a
great boxer and fitness enthusiast
at 9 30 in the morning and instead of
doing that i slept into 11. sergio
worked out for two and a half hours
and then the first thing me and pimp did
is we went downstairs and ate breakfast
and i got a bacon egg and cheese with
[ __ ] wedge potatoes
oh my god dude i know i was doing so
good right wasn't i doing so good
like great with my fitness pal i had
lost like i think like close to 20
pounds and now it's right i mean it is
right
i've completely i've completely went off
dude i'm telling you gotta be careful
with that no but i'm telling you dude
like seriously like and you know people
like listening like this happens like
i was genuinely like depressed sitting
in los angeles like being so far from
home like
and i couldn't even when i tried to be
like chris just go to the gym and don't
mess up with your eating just don't my
mind my depression was just like nope
you you're going to eat and not go to
the gym because somehow
your mind plays [ __ ] yeah it's like it's
more it's way more fun of course
i know now though being home in new york
like i'll i'll start to exercise like
not this morning i had a bacon egg and
cheese and a muffin
but oh my god i don't understand how you
have energy after you eat
what do you think do you think i look
fat right now no i
look you should look like a disaster
right now here you're like oh he looks
fine
yeah you look like you look like a guy
that played football
and now like you know he let it go a
little bit like i
like do you think women would be like
okay his is hot look you're
no no no do i look like a thick man
though like that yeah yeah
so good we're fat and the same we're fed
in the same way
except you have muscles i'm telling you
yes we are whether you like it or not
here's the difference i can't i can't
believe dude clip that
i can't believe that he just said that
go ahead no i'll tell you why okay
i'll tell you why i hate diet joe so
much i'll tell you why we're fat the
same way
you're you have muscles but you're fat
right
i'm skinny but i'm fat if i was in shape
i would just be like a slender dude
right if you were in shape you'd be just
a muscly dude but that doesn't make us
the same because the key difference but
you have no muscles i'm saying here's
the difference here's what i'm saying
here's what i'm saying
that's like this is what i'm saying the
similarity is the similarity is this
neither of us are like you you wouldn't
look at either of us and go that's a fat
dude
right but you might look at us and go
that guy needs to lose some weight which
is the truth
right yeah that's what i'm saying when i
say we're the same kind of fat but i
think to a woman
they don't necessarily like not every
woman they don't care at all
it's it's really if we're getting it
pimp actually said this he had a good
point
when we're getting in shape we're really
getting in shape for other guys because
women don't care dude i had a joke on
one of my specials
about where i where i go late i was like
ladies
please stop banging me i'm never going
to get into shame
yeah if you don't stop having sex with
me yeah like because it's like why would
i even bother
i know every time i take my shirt off
i'm like jazz seriously do i look good
she's like i don't care
she's like you you pay the bills and you
take care of my kids i mean i don't i
mean she's
so out of your league it's crazy
it's crazy dude on every front she's out
of your league you know people will
constantly message me or even come under
the streets be like
you know your daughter's so beautiful
but oh my god they're mothers what a
gorgeous woman and i'm like yeah
i know dude where did you meet her at a
bar
in brooklyn called place to beach in
coney island i went with my friend pat
finnegan
who convinced me to go he were meeting
his sister
and her friends there so that was the
plan and then i saw jasmine
just dancing around on the dance floor
and i was like oh dad i mean i
she couldn't be more my ty i love this
girl and then
and then and then i started you know
tried talking to her and she
literally wanted nothing to do with me
she was like you're coming on
like she was like guy like get away from
me right i was like all right let me
just buy i remember i remember i kept
sending over
vodka uh raspberry strawberry vodka and
seltzers
and she was like i don't want these and
i just kept i just kept sending them
over
and then i like literally like wore her
down to the point where she was like
all right like what do you do i was like
i do i'm a comedian and she was like
i've never heard of you or seen you
[Laughter]
and i was like i do comedy and then
she's like all right like message me and
then i messed and she came to a show
like
three weeks later did she think you were
funny well you know what i got so lucky
is i did i did uh maguire's comedy club
out all the way out in bohemia
long island like suffolk county which is
like my people like i didn't sell any
tickets but like
they laughed at my kind of pig humor
right so she thought it was like a trick
because like if i would have went like
did that [ __ ] at like the comedy cellar
they would be like boo
but all the way out there you know i was
doing jokes about like you know
imitating my italian dad and selling
that stuff
and they're like oh yeah and then the
owner jimmy who's a great guy like
treated me because i told him i was like
i'm on a date so he like rolled out the
red carpet and was like this [ __ ] got
one of the best comedians you'll ever
see like he played it up and then she
was like oh [ __ ]
and then we went out on a couple more
dates and then i just trapped her dude
i got her pregnant and then she had no
escape once she had got pregnant wow i
trapped her for sure
wow wow yeah she was like
because i think like it's the same thing
that happened with my mom and dad
my mom realized what a mistake she made
with my father while she was like six
months pregnant
with me because my dad like his nose is
crooked his glasses are always on
sideways and she was like
what did i do so they like immediately
got divorced and i think jasmine had the
same epiphany she was like
what am i doing with this idiot like we
we're making a child
but now we got two so dude what can you
do but we got beautiful little girls but
it's
yeah dude i think she literally at times
has been like i mean i
you know like what like i can't she said
before she's like you know girls
think you're cute she said this on the
christy ks podcast she's like girls may
think you're cute she's like but if they
knew how
absolutely disgusting you were i saw
that clip yeah because and she was meant
to dude she was like you're
like insanely disgusting i bite my
toenails
ew no you don't dude i do
you bite your toenails yes you pull your
foot up to your mouth and bite your toes
well i did before i be but then i put on
too much weight now i don't have the
flexibility to get my foot to my mouth
but as soon as i start doing yoga again
i'm going to put my big toe right in my
mouth why would you do that
because i do because i have mental
issues what else do you do
pick my nose that's who cares yeah
fart a lot right um but the most just oh
and i eat my earwax
ew chris that's disgusting what dude i'm
being honest and vulnerable and you're
making me feel bad
good you should feel bad about yourself
that's disgusting dude
seriously if you said we pretty much
have the same body no i didn't say that
what about pimp what do you think
homeless pimp looks like do you think
he's had a better or worse body than us
be honest
i think we're all in the same field here
we're all we're all guys who
who for sure should get back in the gym
more regularly i don't say anything with
the same body i said we're fat in the
same way
that when somebody looks at you they
don't go that's a fat guy
that's just a guy that needs to get into
shape that's it i don't think anybody
looks at me and goes he's fat
they just go look at your double chin
you got to lose some weight
you know what i mean no you know you
don't look fat you actually look good
you chris dude you do bro you bro you're
one of those guys you look used to look
horrific
back like back in like the opie anthony
days or like your first special dude you
look brutal
you look like you and nate bargati had
the same syndrome where you both used to
look like legitimate lesbians
10 years ago and now you guys are both
like handsome good-looking guys
i definitely grew into my looks a little
bit yeah i would say that but i also too
i uh
this ad federal trade committee no but
go oh this bad pod
okay hey this podcast sponsored by
betterhelp we love this uh we love this
ad here at hey babe
because it's it's helping people with
their mental health dude i use it
a lot of my friends use it better help
it's it assesses your needs it matches
you with a therapist that you need
it's all on zoom no waiting rooms
nobody's got a
you know you don't got to worry about if
somebody's going to hear my problems you
can
do it privately you know you don't got
to tell anybody you're in it you just
literally log on to zoom people could
think that you're
watching porn or something but you're
really talking to your therapist which
there's been times where therapy can be
porn can be therapeutic and i'm not
saying you can't watch porn while
talking to your therapist
that's up to you and your therapist to
discuss that but my point is that better
health
allows you to have the kind of
relationship with your therapist that
other places don't because it's on zoom
so you want to do therapy with no pants
on do it do it as long as you clear with
the therapist
the services available for clients
worldwide dude you could literally be in
communist china
and you can get better help well maybe
not them because they control the
internet
but you you you probably could you could
definitely get it if you were in like
you know madagascar you can get it which
is a great movie
um and you get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you can do it on the phone if you
don't want to do it on video i forgot to
mention you can do it on the phone
and we're going to give you guys a nice
discount get your mental health in check
please for me
do it babe all you got to do is go to
betterhelp
that's help betterhelp.com
hey babe you're going to get 10 off your
first month betterhelp.com
hey babe 10 off your first month get
your mental health and check
yo soy cristobal this ad babble dude
where did i learn how to say yo soy
cristobal
babble okay 15 minute lessons i learned
spanish baby
you can learn all these different type
of languages if you want to learn a
language on the go
if you're going to another country
because they listed their covert
restrictions and you want to learn that
language babble
if you're trying to illegally smuggle
yourself into some type of terrorist
network
and you need to learn the language
quickly to fit in with the infidels
babble
okay or are we the infidels i always
forget infidel castro
um babel.com first of all it's better
than all the other learning language
apps out there i genuinely swear to god
i use it and now i can understand a
little bit
when my girl and my family are talking
[ __ ] about me in spanish i know what
they're saying
okay i know where the punta is now so
oputo
is that a bad word maybe it is if i i'm
sorry i love you babel
here's what you could do they got 14
different languages they could choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german
and they got the speech recognition
technology which helps you improve your
pronunciation
and accent it's so important to know the
accent and babel actually does a great
job of doing that
and here's what you could do if you
purchase a three-month babble
subscription
and then you go to babble.com and put in
the promo code hey babe you get an extra
three months for free
so go to b-a-b-b-e-l.com put in the code
hey babe
buy the three-month subscription and you
can get another three for free
so you're getting literally six months
for the price of three because i'm good
at math
okay so go to babel.com and learn the
language i want to learn how to say
suck it joe derosa in 14 different
languages and babble's the place to do
it
babble.com hey babble.com promo code hey
babe
i got to get back to where i was when i
lived in la my second or
my second year in la i did paleo i
lifted dumbbells and i did cardio
right and i [ __ ] dude i was down to
like
182 pounds what do you weigh now like
203.
oh so you could 20 pounds is for a guy
dude you could you could
i was just in the zone dude it was like
like people were like
like i heard new comics from new york
that always trashed me
for being out of shape when they would
come to new york and i'd see l.a and i'd
see them they'd be like
dude you look good man so how did you
combat the la depression because you're
like me like a northeast east coast guy
well because when i first moved out
there you know i
i found a group of friends to drink with
the comics i liked that like
like divy bars and stuff so that was one
thing
i was working like crazy like i moved
out there i booked
within like two weeks of being there i
booked a pilot i was the star of the pa
of a pilot and what happened to that it
blew up and became one of the biggest tv
shows of all time it didn't go what do
you think happened to it
yeah yeah yeah the star of a pilot
yeah i booked the lead on an animated
pilot for fox
that's actually pretty sick it was huge
animated is the way to go too because
you just go to a
crazy dude yeah roll out of bed and just
go right in yeah
i know i keep trying to convince sal i'm
like hey man i got an animated show idea
he texts back to everything you know
sal's are one of our best friends he
texts back to everything so quick
but every time like hey man what do you
think of this animated show right there
just leaves it on red
he's like i don't want to do an animated
show with you you pig
so that was i got that i was already
writing on the pete holm show
so i was gainfully employed i booked a
pilot then right after i booked the
starring role in the pilot i booked
better call saul
and that was a recurring and then
pete's show ended and i booked red hot
american summer and i was writing for
it was just like one and then i got my
special my hour special
it was one thing after the next dude and
so i was so just in the zone of like i'm
supposed to be here
and i had my i had my like comedy boys
that i would like go drink with
i didn't care that the stage time sucked
because i was working on all these other
things
and then i was meeting like chicks dude
i was like doing really well with chicks
and stuff and having a good time like
how crazy is it that you did
all that and still i mean not even close
the biggest thing you've ever done is
taste buds
i know like like it's like it's not even
close dude i know dude
it's the same by the way same for me
it's not even close the biggest thing
i've done i i owe the fans of no presh
and and in particular taste buds so much
dude because i was like talking
i was talking the other day to jay
okerson and i was like dude it's so nice
to finally feel like
you're on like common ground with your
friends i was like a lot of my friends
have had shows like this for a long time
and yeah
i i was like you know it's it's always
been an uphill [ __ ] battle for me no
not anymore well
it's because of the well you know it's
because of the fans but also homeless
pimp we need to protect
by the way not that we're like we're
talking as if we're not retiring off of
the no
pressure network no no we're we're
shocked
we're we're we're elated by the influx
of support i think the difference is
is like you know you used to like have
to try to go get a tv show and do this
but now it's like this is our tv show
like our fans now are supporting us to a
way that's like giving
you know it's like just beautiful it's
like it's just a beautiful
time to be alive we gotta protect the
homeless pimp dude if the homeless pimp
here's the thing i can eat pizza at
night because i'm just replaceable you
just get some other dingbat to get in
here
and keep going but if pimp dies what
would we do i don't even know how to
press record
dude i don't know dude we have to
protect the pimp i mean look
as long as he gives us this equipment
we'll figure it out i get it
right yeah but i mean like jesus god
yeah dude any one of us is replacement
look at what we do one of us isn't here
we're just like just do my show instead
of the other guy no i know dude
it doesn't matter bro do you know do you
realize like how many dms i got
this past weekend from women being like
yo where's the pimp as the pimp single
because the pimp is not answering at the
ends and they're like we got a better
chance of chris to stefano
getting it getting us in touch with the
pimp than the pimp himself yeah he's
turning into a [ __ ] monster
we have to keep him on a leash the
ladies are after pimp i know big time
dude
what do you think of that pimp how do
you feel about that uh it sounds
dangerous they sound like issues
dude when you get a haircut and leave
your beard you look like a school
shooter right
he looks like big lebowski uh he looks
like john goodman in big labour he does
look like john goodman
look he's look he's got the nobody's a
handsome he's got him i know but he's
good so is john goodman but he's got the
floral shirt on look it's literally the
same thing
about it bring the picture up put up the
big lebowski with john goodman
i am which by the way it's a movie i've
never seen is that oh dude you're
missing out man really i've never seen
any movies really
i know you ever seen the austin powers
movies yes dude i met somebody the other
day i've never seen austin powers
dude it's what the phone is birth
control oh that's my parking meter
oh [ __ ] yeah i got to pay the parking
meter too where are we at time wise pimp
about a half hour we're at a half an
hour oh my god this show just drags
dude look at look at goodman and big
lebowski
look at him right there dude it does wow
dude no yeah click that picture with the
one with john goodman on the on the
bottom left that one yeah one more over
there you go that wow holy [ __ ] dude
that's wild isn't it that's it's
actually i've never even realized that
i never realized until today because
when you said his haircut
no his haircut is perfect dude but we
should throw a hey babe bit at de rosa
uh
i think the fans want to know how your
first kiss went
how'd your first kiss go oh it went
pretty good man i
i got to second base on my first kiss
what how old were you
12. holy [ __ ] but i first got in
we we were watching a movie and i got to
feel
like we during them we hadn't kissed yet
during the movie i felt her up
under the bra during the movie what
movie
what movie couldn't tell you if my life
depended on i think it might have been
the exorcist
it might have been let's go that i'll
get you nice and horny yeah
and then uh nothing makes you want to
feel 12 year old tits like the exorcist
yeah
and then we went outside we went outside
it was at my cousin's house in
in cherry hill new jersey or delray new
jersey and then we went outside now it
was actually a nice little
actually you know cherry on the you know
i know cherry on new jersey because i
used to do gigs with soldier all there
yeah yeah
i know dude i've gone to some far
reaches with soldiers you ever do the
robin's nest
with him instead i think that was the
one in cherry hill
no no i've done some we've got i've gone
way
deep upstate with him and stuff like but
you know what dude to be honest with you
i don't care how big at least i'll speak
for me how big my
career ever got i would always do soulja
there's just something nostalgic about
work with him i love it no i love joel i
i went back and did it when it was an
indoor club i was like one of the first
comics to go down and do his indoor club
because you don't have any other gigs
though that's why you did it
you do it by choice man oh my god all
right so
i really do stink so you're feeling uh
so you're feeling up this girl's
when you're 12 years old and you're
literally then we went outside we went
outside and we went on in
there was like this pine tree that had
like this little like
i remember like alcove or something
where you could like kind of go inside
of where the tree was and be surrounded
by the branches
oh nice romantic it was cool and then i
we made out in there that was my first
kiss
wow for like you know 30 seconds or
whatever it was
oh my god but it went pretty well did
you ever kiss her again
no i never saw her ever again wow that
that's a 12 year old one night stand
and then lose yeah and then i lose my
virginity went really well too
what happened you gotta tell sad how old
were you i was old dude i was 21.
you didn't lose your virginity until you
were 21. i was 21 but i lost it to a 37
year old
college professor from a school that i
had
gone to previously that i left wow
that's like
porn status yeah it was awesome when she
got
she got she was like she was moving to
georgia
and she was like look i can't we went on
a first date and she's like look i can't
uh
like i i like you like you seem like a
nice guy but like she's like i can't do
this like this is gonna go nowhere i'm
moving away and like i'm not into casual
stuff anymore
i'm too old for that just took your
virginity no it's before she took my
virginity
just on the first date and on the date i
told her i go look i'm not that guy
like i'm not the kind of guy i'm a
virgin i just told her
and then like the end of the day ended
kind of awkwardly and she
she like came out and uh i was walking
away because i didn't make a move and i
was so mad at myself and i was like
idiot idiot and she came running out of
her house
towards me and she tapped me on the
shoulder and she's like hey and i go hey
and she's like
you haven't ever dated an older woman
have you and i go no
and she started making out with me and
then she goes
i'll let's hang out again and the second
time we hung out she goes i'm going to
tell you
i like the idea of being your first
wow and then like on the third date she
like had it all set up all her furniture
had been moved already
and she set up like this air mattress
with blankets and pillows and
candles and stuff so when we went home
after the date we could have sex for the
i could have sex with her for the first
time but were you able first of all did
you use a condom
yeah did you even know how to like put
it on or get it up or were you so
nervous you couldn't even get it out no
i got it way up i couldn't get it up my
first time
why would you not know how to put a
condom on i didn't use a condom my first
time my very
the very first time i had sex like lost
my virginity not only did i not use a
condom i
came inside of her oh my god we were 17
years old i would have had a panic
attack
i was so scared about everything at that
point but see but but
i think because you were 21 if that
would have happened to me at 21
i would have been the same as you but by
17 i was a senior i didn't learned any
of that stuff yet or
i learned i was reckless by 17. i would
have been worse at 17
the older i got the more comfortable i
got right i wouldn't have been able to
have sex at 17. that's why i
was 21. did she say it was good like for
like she did she said i i remember it
lasted five minutes
not bad and she goes i go is that okay
she's like you did pretty good for
somebody who's never had sex and i was
like oh great
uh one time you guys did it or that was
it and then we
if i remember correctly when i woke up
in the morning she had left
for like georgia so you actually haven't
even seen this person
never saw her again listen if that
lady's listening to this episode of hey
babe
please email heybaypodcast gmail.com and
the homeless pimp will
will talk to you and we'll get you on
zoom i remember she moved to athens
georgia
because she was telling me how uh my
university is there michael stipe from
rem lived there and that's where her new
job was
well she was probably working at the
university of georgia then i guess i
don't know that that's where
wow that's a crazy dude could you
imagine yeah
great town that's a fun comedy you've
been there oh yeah you think there's a
difference between athens georgia and
athens greece
uh probably not
yeah dude just the same pig speaking of
speaking to greece pope franc what did
you say
pope francis pimp pulled up an article
yeah i wanted uh de rosa i've never
heard deroza go on aliens yet
so what is pope francis saying though
now aliens meaning
outer space he would baptize aliens so
pope francis said
he would baptize aliens who are we to
close doors so if aliens came to this
planet francis said he baptized them
into the catholic community this is a
joke right
no no it's dead serious no but i mean
like people are we really considering
that aliens are going to land here they
want to be baptized
all right keeps baby this ad is from my
friends
who are suffering from a little mpb male
pattern baldness which guess what is two
out of three men
so two out of the three guys listening
right now you might have a little bald
spot you don't know about or maybe you
do know about it because your wife or
girlfriend said hey baldilox
why don't you go to keeps.com and get
your hair grown back more than 50
million men in the u.s suffer from male
power and baldness
that's a lot of people dude okay so more
than 50 million men
in the u.s suffer from male pattern
baldness is it because of the vaccine we
don't know
there are only two fda approved
medications that could prevent hair loss
and keeps
offers them both it's a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair it's
low-cost treatment's only 10 bucks a
month
discreet packaging and proven results so
nobody knows that you're getting this
hair loss
uh treatment so it's in discrete
discreet packaging and prevention is key
okay so
let me tell you something it could take
four to six months to see results so act
fast if your hair is starting to look
like a
dandelion blown in the wind it's time to
go to keeps.com
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com that's
k
e e p s dot com slash hey babe and
you're gonna receive your first month of
treatment
for free okay not for five dollars not
for free baby that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash hey babe get your first month free
send us a picture of your bald spots
and then send us a picture of what keeps
did to help you that's what i want or
email to heybaypodcast gmail.com or just
tweet me at christy comedy or at
salvakana i want to see your bald spots
and i want to see how keeps improved it
okay
keeps.com keps.com
hey babe get your first month free canva
pro
you know me i'm chrissy canvapro i'm not
big with with with you know internet
tools and websites but homeless pimp is
homeless pimp edits
all the videos with canva pro right
pimpy yep i love it so you what do you
love about it
you can just go there and you get all
these photos and video assets that you
can use you can even design your
business cards there
wow it's like a one-stop shop for
anything digital creative stuff
yeah they have a content planner you'll
save time planning creating and posting
social media content too so everybody's
doing that especially with everybody
working from home
pretty much or you know majority of
people canva pro helps with all this
stuff
it really is like awesome it's got
endless premium fonts
photos videos and so much more that add
personality and edge to whatever you're
designing because who doesn't love
edging
so canvas canva pro is the thing to do
especially if you want to design like a
pro and you're into that stuff canva pro
so the people who are into this
listen i understand some people maybe
don't you know know even about computers
and they're like i don't know anything
about this fine
but most people you know there there is
a healthy percentage of listeners that
are like hey
i need a new design platform i need
something to design canva pro is the
thing that to do
it empowers you to create all new it
empowers you to create and share
stunning content
in just a few clicks dude and it
empowers you to get out there and
protest your rights
for your rights whether you're a design
professional or just an idiot like me
canva pro is easy to use we're going to
give you guys a nice dis discount too
go to canva.me canva.me
slash hey babe get your free 45-day
extended trial that's c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e slash hey babe canva dot me
slash hey babe 45 day free trial
they give you a free trial for every day
uh they give you a free trial they give
you 45 free days
for president number 45. i made that
part up so just
i'm just kidding it's hey babe i love
you i'm kidding canva dot
canva dot me slash hey babe are you not
considering aliens are real
i think they're real i think the last
thing in their on their mind is
will we get baptized when we go to earth
no i know i'm not saying that that's
what that's on their itinerary but if
they got here and settled in
i feel like it's not really a heavy
question weighing on the minds of people
that we need to
take up the pope's time to ask well that
that's how you know when the media is
just running out of questions that's
what i mean
is this just like was this like one of
the funny questions at the press
conference i mean no this is legit what
are this is the independent they're
legit
are they i don't know well that's the
thing like dude with me like i don't
know who's legit who's not like
i remember one time i think i might have
been talking to you or i was talking to
like a you know more cerebral
smart friend and i i was telling him
about something with like maybe it was
like about covert or maybe it's about
some type of political issue and i was
like i was like yeah dude i read it in
the new york post and they were like
yeah that that means it's not real i was
like what do you mean
they were like the new york post is
garbage i was like what i took it as
bible fact
the post and the times now at this point
the times there was a time where
the times held out credibility a little
bit longer than the posted
in my opinion but now the post and the
times are equally as absurd
in my opinion uh but the post is much
more like wearing it on their sleeve
which i actually respect a little bit
more like the post like will be a little
more flamboyant
yeah we know where it kind of dumb they
don't even it's not even that they're
just exploitative
like the headline the post headlines are
always hilarious it's like the sun it's
like
yeah it's great yeah so who is a
reputable newspaper then like who should
i read
i don't think you can consider any
corporate news outlet reputable
at this point i truly don't think so do
you think people should just get their
news from hey babe and taste buds
probably i mean denzel washington the
greatest quote of all time about it what
do you say it goes if you don't read the
news you're uninformed if you read the
news you're misinformed it's the
greatest quote of all time about that
it's it just sums it all up if you don't
read the news you're
uninformed if you read the news you're
misinformed wow dude yeah
dude when you hear a great quote like
that did you make does a party want to
get a tattooed on you you love tattoos
no but dude let's talk about your tattoo
dude i'm getting them removed
you're getting it removed i'm getting a
bunch of them removed yeah or or one
again how many do you have
i got three what is this one first okay
this one says in your mercy keep us free
from sin
and protect us from all anxiety because
they say that
in catholic in my catholic church at
saint matthias they would say that and
then when people
read that they're like nobody says that
they don't say the word anxiety
in scripture i'm like yes they do dude
you are such
brooklyn trash i can't even wrap my head
around it dude
i can't even wrap my head around it dude
dude and then this one is the buildings
i grew up like you're such
brooklyn trash you're such brooklyn
trash i can't believe you're in an
interracial relationship
because i would peg you for a filth
racist
[Laughter]
dude i yeah i no have you told derosa
you were in the tattoo magazine recently
yeah i was in
inked magazine for what like for that
come on dude yeah for that and the one
on my arm cuz
dude you know what a p you know you have
to be new york trash when i put
established 1984 in new york city
oh my god dude look at you
when you just put your what does that
say kitten no
those are letters that's an anagram
what's that what any acronym
sorry and that could have for what when
i met george carlin he said keep kicking
them in the nuts and i got the letters
put on my arm and you think that's what
he wanted for you to put in an acronym
on the
was my title and that's the advice he
gave young comics and he said it to me
and i was excited that he said it to me
and i put it on my arm
here's my idol now it gets all serious
it's better than established new york
city you
pig dude like you're a forefather here
oh george harlan told you that you got
so inspired
by george cullen that you got the word
that you got the words keep kicking in
the nuts from your comedy or tattoo your
arm
and then he decided to open his sandwich
shop that's not what he meant
that's what i'm gonna get joey rose's
established 2021
new york city oh my god that literally
is in the investor deck pimp
the investor deck we have in one of the
logo variations it says joey rose's
sandwich
established 2021 that's what trash you
are
is that you get sandwich shop logos on
your body on your body
it's pertaining to your life yeah it's
brutal dude
it's brutal there's a
it's a big cross on my back oh my god
dude and i
moved to coney island and opened up a
stand where you throw bottle
balls at milk bottles
oh my god how about this i got the cross
on my back
and then the guy the tattoo artist
because he's my friend's brother and he
would do it like late night it would be
free it would just tip him
he put a big cross on my back and then
he wrote the word faith at the bottom
and i didn't ask him and write the word
faith
he just free-balled it he free-handed he
was like i thought it would mix i
thought it would mesh well and
then i looked at it like dude i didn't
want
faith but he did it for free so i was
like ah [ __ ] it now i've never been
tattooed before how much pressure is it
like as soon as the needle hits you you
regret it or um you start to get numb
from the pain to be
the one on my back like genuinely hurt
because he was working on
like somewhere in my mid spine for like
20 minutes and i start to like lose a
little bit of feeling in my
mind there's certain there's certain
areas that hurt in certain areas that
aren't too bad
this area right here hurts so bad from
the jump
from the jump and i was just like i got
to get through this
well also it definitely helps if you
have a couple drinks beforehand i don't
care what it whatever they go don't
shut up have a few drinks it loosens you
up because the more you think the less
you
if you're loose it doesn't hurt how many
taps do you
if you're tense how many do you have do
you have any on your back
or torso or just your arms on my back
who am i a
chick from queens no i have one on my
back i know you do
no i i just have the ones on my arms one
two three four
five i'm getting another one here and
another one here see i was just gonna
ask you i'm glad you said that because
i'm genuinely like
dead seriously considering getting like
a sleeve but
b i'm going to be 37 next month is that
too old am i too old to get like
a sleeve dude everybody has tattoos now
don't get these removed just get them
like adapted into something
so somebody could make a sleeve around
this yes of course why couldn't that but
then what do they just cover it like
with ink or some [ __ ] like that
no like you're saying if you get this
covered this is going to be tough
but i'm sure that they could at least
look that incorporated into a sleeve
wouldn't look that bad
that by itself on your forearm like it's
your credo
yeah looks absurd it looks absurd i know
right after i'm
on a pirate scroll by the way i know my
mother when my mother she was like i
actually don't mind that you have
tattoos she's like but why would you get
she called this a manifesto
she goes why would you get a manifesto
on your phone yeah my mom's really smart
dude
i know it was like she was like why
would you do that honey like get
something like that on your back
now how long did you think about getting
that before you got it all three of my
tattoos
all three of them i was going through a
really bad breakup i got all three of my
tattoos within a six-month time frame
and all three of them
i thought up the morning i got them so
so they're all like ones and i'm like
what am i doing i mean i
look i go impetuous sometimes with
tattoos yeah i go real impetuous like
get it
the day of or the next day just make an
appointment i decided i want the frasier
logo on my arm and i'm just gonna get it
and i know i might regret it one day but
i'm just like i'm going to get it i
don't care
we'll see how we only live once see
because i said well i thought about i
said
what tattoos do i want to get on my body
that i'll never regret no matter what
and i thought oh things i'll always be
proud of are my neighborhood and my
religion
and then as the years went on i was like
oh i don't care about religion anymore
and then i moved out of that
neighborhood
so so i was like oh [ __ ] so now the next
tattoos i'm going to get because now
being older it's just going to be stuff
for my daughters you know
oh my god dude you piece
of [ __ ] i can't get my daughter's names
tattooed oh my god dude
what is the matter with you what do you
want me to get what
what are you gonna do dude you would get
the ninja turtles tattooed on you
somewhere
it's better than your daughter's names
what does that matter with you
how is it how you're just so you'll give
me this tattoo
look at this oh you live in the bay
ridge river
or whatever that body of water is called
over there go
live in it you are disgusting
true tv i implore you cancel backyard
bars
this man does not deserve to be on
public television
period because of the people at true tv
i just bought a house on staten island
what do you think of that
oh my god dude you picked one of the
three islands
that stink staten island
long island yeah what was the other one
we talked about
we were talking the other day rhode
island island the staten island of new
england
you think island you usually think
paradise beautiful water
you know indigenous people find cuisine
except for
three of them staten island island
i can't believe you don't like that idea
i was here's the idea here's no tell me
if
it's not an idea eight million other
people have done it that means it's not
an idea no but here's what you haven't
seen a lot i have
both from my daughters both like from
the first day
of their i have their very first
heartbeats i have both of them so i was
going to get that on my arm
and not say anything and then when
people ask what is that it's just a
squiggly line it's like
no i guess it's delilah's first
heartbeat this is violet's first
heartbeat i got some other great ideas
for you
get your first dog's uh paw print on you
on your arm how about that get something
in memorium to your nana that's original
uh maybe a barbed wire strap around
around up here around your bicep what
are you what does your tattoo say
zapaloo zappo is yeah but it's original
what does that even mean it means the
spirit of frank zappa his artistic motto
it lives on that's what it means now you
cannot like it
but it's original wait a minute so all
your tattoos are inspired by
art you like and all yours are inspired
by sex
yeah yes yeah yeah yeah
dude why don't you just get a why don't
you just get a quarter pound of
mortadella tattooed on your leg
i swear to god i i swear to god i
thought about getting an italian hoagie
tattooed on my arm do it
i know a guy that's got one on his chest
he's got an italian hoagie on his swear
to god he's got an italian hoagie
tattooed on
he gets an italian hoagie on his forum
how's that going to make you feel pimp
amazing i'll give a sandwich i would get
a sandwich in a i'll tell you what
if you pay for it i'll get an italian
hoagie tattooed on my arm
this week if you pay for it dude
i'm going hamskis on breakfast you think
i'm going to pay for a tattoo if you pay
for it
you know what fine i'll do it honestly i
swear to god i'll pay for the italian
hoagie
tattoo on your arm and we'll put the
footage of it on the patreon right here
i swear to god i'll pay for his i'll pay
for something right here but here's my
only stipulation it's got to be a black
and white
what is the price range it'll be like
200 bucks you want to leave that watch
down to do it dude i'm down to do it
well how much time
okay this is not a false promise i will
do this dude
i'm i would once once i commit and say
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it dude
okay
that's it dude dude wow he's gonna pay
oh dude this week he's going to get
pimped so you have to be available
because we that's it's going to go on
the patreon
let's go this weekend yeah and then you
know what maybe i'll get maybe i'll sit
down and get a sleeve
or no you can't you can't get a sleeve
in one sitting
what is the matter with you do you not
know
anything i mean dude i
have known a lot of dumb people in my
day dude but you're way
up the ladder have you ever met someone
as dumb as me that has a level of
education i have
no i mean and that is incredible because
yeah chris is a doctorate he i mean it
just goes to show you being a doctor
it's just memorizing things that's
really all it is
yeah either that i mean did you cheat
your way through med school no
i didn't do it well i didn't go to med
school i'm a physical therapist so i got
a clinical doctorate
all right there we go that now it makes
sense you thought that being a physical
therapist made you go to med school it's
like med school
i went through graduate school and got a
clinical doctorate at the end of a three
and a half
years you're a nurse basically yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right that's fine
that's fine
i'd also like to know have you ever been
cheated on or wrote a woman a love
letter oh my god the
overwhelming yes to both of them i'll
let them explain it but there's no way
he hasn't gone through
dude joe derosa is the most hopeless
romantic man
i've ever met in my life i'm such a
romantic
i i never i've never been cheated on
really never i thought you did i thought
you went through something when you got
cheated on
i've had my heart broken in different
ways but i don't think i was ever
true traditionally you may not have
known but maybe yeah yeah
uh the one time a girl slept with
somebody else
and i was very hurt we were in a
technically open relationship
but she broke the rule and brought a
dude back to her apartment and the rule
was we weren't allowed to bring people
back to our apartment
well how does that any different than a
hotel i was in college it was because we
lived next door to each other and that
was the role we had it's like you went
from dude it's like you you lose your
virginity at 21 to a college professor
and then immediately you're in an open
relationship dude i think i think i
think
you i think you having sex with the
older woman messed you up a little bit
it might have i
yeah i think i think looking back i
think it was abuse
how did you get into the open
relationship you set that up or she set
that up
i think it was her idea but i agreed
with it because i knew that i wasn't
i've always had commitment issues and at
that point in my life i was probably
only 20 i was still probably only 21 or
22.
i was a tail into college for me i had
because of my catholic upbringing i had
a lot of
subconscious subliminal stuff with sex
like when i had sex i would feel
terribly like damn dirty afterwards
i was terrified i was going to get a
disease like as punishment
same it was horrible same thing so like
her saying i want to be in an open thing
and like i can't commit to you
like i it made sense to me because we
had had sex and i had that bad
feeling afterwards and i was like well
obviously i shouldn't and there was
nothing wrong with her it's just
it was just [ __ ] i was working through
which i eventually got over
yeah but but anyway um so no i've never
been cheated on in the traditional sense
uh i'm sure
i've written a love poem or a love
letter i mean i'm not remember
i remember when i was a freshman in high
school i had no game whatsoever and i
bought
teddy bears on valentine's day the
school shop
sold teddy bears in like little bags
holding hearts and i bought one
for each of these two girls i had a
crush on one who had a boyfriend
uh and i thought like that was like a
good move and i remember hearing
oh man this is brutal i remember being
in a theology class
in theology class uh i sat like in a row
over from the one of the girls i bought
it for and i heard her
like talking to her friend before class
like yeah i mean
it's weird he gave me this my bear he
sent it to me
and i looked over because i heard them
talking about me and then she saw that i
caught her talking about me and she went
hi joe thank you for the bear and like
had to put like this face on
uh it was brutal dude it was brutal you
just feel like a sack of [ __ ] right yeah
and then her boyfriend came up to me
he's like you know she's going out with
me right and i was like
yeah and he was like why'd you do that i
was like
i don't know oh my god you put your name
on i thought you meant like secret
admirer
no no i put my name on because i was
like i
in ninth grade i thought like i went to
such a i went to such a small grade
school like my graduating class of my
grade school had like 15 kids in it
it was a small catholic school so
it wasn't that uncommon in my grade
school for like if somebody was like
going out with somebody
else for like somebody to just make a
play because you were just like there
was no
these were your only options here's the
badge so i had no i when i got into a
school with like hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of kids i had no idea at
first how to adapt to that
here's the bad news for me is as we're
doing this episode
is we've literally had the same
upbringing and have pretty much
the same life and the same body and the
same but i know dude and the same body
and i'm six years younger than you and
now i see my future
and it's not good no dude i never
realized that all
i'm that literally joe derosa is just
six years ahead of me but it's this same
trajectory yeah
it's what it is dude i'm gonna when i'm
43 i'm just gonna be sick how old are
you
36 36 oh yeah dude welcome to the club
i had tv shows 36.
now i didn't have house money because
none of my tv shows never got picked up
but i was selling pilots and all
when i was 36 dude it's it's you dude
this is where you're headed buddy having
a full television show on true tv is
like having a pilot on cbs it's the same
thing
it's the same and then dude it just no
matter what i do
i'm always going to wind up just on a
couch that barely fits in my living room
with quilts my nana's made
that's my mom made this my mommy made
this oh your mommy made that that's nice
yeah she knits these from scratch well
can i get one
if you want one you got to pay her for a
time though i'll pay her for a time why
don't why don't we
why don't we make it merch kim said oh
my god like that's shitty of me
dad yeah i want you want my mom to make
it for him for free
look at the size of this thing dude yeah
they need the money they live in
i just love that you're pitching him her
rates are right now no
i'm not i wouldn't make he said she goes
tell her to make me one i said oh
[ __ ] how do we do it why don't we why
don't we hire joe's mom to do merch
and make quilts would you guys like hay
babe and taste buds and no pressure
listen
i know you did i know i know they they
probably would
the up cost we're gonna have to charge
you a lot more because if you think my
mom is cranking these things out like
one a day i mean dude this takes a while
dude what's so up man we'll charge a
premium dude we'll make them like 500
dollars
to put the no pressure logo they're nice
colors man nice color yeah well
listen i gotta ask my mom if she's
willing to be a part of this
but if you do want it just let us know
if you'd be interested and we'll see if
it's something we can work out
but this is not like the hoagie promise
look my boxers are coming out past my
shorts
you're disgusting dude just why are you
wearing biker shorts under your shorts
i'm not these are tommy john underwear
which i thought were good but i
farted holes through all of them and now
they're coming out through my i'm
wearing
like jasmine this morning was like what
is the deal with your short shorts
lately like what is ha why are you why
are you all instead of wearing short
shorts i was like i don't know dude
it's the ones that bare bottom clothing
sent me
i love bear bottom clothing i like bare
bottom i got some bear bottle and stuff
in the clothes
yeah yeah promo code yeah oh all right
all right um all right listen i'm gonna
go put on because we're gonna record a
taste buds
after this but you're to see it before
you see this
which is the funky thing are you going
to go out in between and have to smoke
cigarettes
no need a cigarette break no what i'm
going to go do right now is i'm going to
go put on the sauce
that i made last night with the
meatballs and pork in it
and warm it up slowly so we can eat some
of it on taste buds
nice all right yeah but but does this go
against your diet
no i made it within the confines of my
diet
oh you know what we forgot to do in the
beginning of the show is sing a song we
normally sing a song like and call like
hey babe like
like last week's words from the back to
the middle and around again i'm gonna be
here to the end 100
hey babe so what can we do what can we
quickly interject hey
that's cool i've been doing that on my
other podcast for four years but uh
are you serious every episode
every episode my parents my my patrick
walsh my colorist would say on with the
show and on with the
instead of and he would say on with the
joe and they would sing a popular song
but
work my name into it ah damn it so we're
hacks
i mean i knew there was a reason that
show took off so quickly
it just collects from other shows
so what can we do what do you got quick
what do you got quick that's
that could be like because you're
supposed to start the show with it but
let's end with it
a song yeah like something you could
just put hey babe quickly into the
lyrics
okay give me give me a second hold on
let me think for a second
um uh hey
[Music]
is
[Music]
hey what's going on hey babe
hey babe all right that was great dude
now i gotta can i can i i got a poo poo
i gotta chill i'll go you go i'm gonna
start the potty sauce
start doing your ads while i put the pot
of sauce how about i just [ __ ] in your
pot of sauce my
face now all right oh is that the end
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey